bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france larouche élections
présidentielle et législatives demain
une trentaine de candidats d'opposition
le risque n'est-il pas que cette
opposition apparaît s'est désuni auquel
on se régale de la cartographie
d'acteurs politiques dans les contextes
aux nigériens que ses positions soient
endicia c'est déjà une trentaine de
candidats ali sont actuellement c'est là
à l'an passé devant un jeu si vous
voulez la position du parti au pouvoir
ne savais plus si l'opposition
nigérienne elle est certes elle a certes
montré un visage uni mais lorsque les
avons déjà on se rend compte qu'elle
était sérieusement tabassé par le
conflit elle un terme à cette opposition
elle est même sérieusement confrontés à
des défis des visibilités à les défis
mais mort si vous voulez des portages de
ses attentes
aujourd'hui les populations nigériennes
autant du point de vue sécuritaire mais
alors nommait de base ou par un grand
favori et il aimait des nigériens
jouait-il d'une bonne popularité d'une
bonne image
je crois que sa part que la crise est
quand même dans le fait que si vous les
bienvenus
avec baissant de la sécurité dans les
selles et au niger de façon particulière
la question communautaire et l'aise
c'est tout le défi du jour soit de nos
minorités qui s'est parfois étiquetté
d'être en déphasage avec le poids
central de niamey je pense que c'est un
atout qui n'est pas à négliger même dans
le même temps au régal sa trajectoire
politique également
mais c'est pas humain apparaît au
générique j'ai rien fait activement
cette foutue président fédérateur c'est
que c'est plaisant qui sait capable
surtout d'asseoir soul et un dialogue
substantiel avec aujourd'hui ses actes
et de la violence qui sévit ce temps
d'aller raison du nord déjà l'insulté
cette fois c'est notamment les quatre
points qui affiche à la libye le mali le
burkina et les négociations non on parle
beaucoup de l'insécurité au nivelles et
malheureusement l'insécurité
grandissante va souvent de pair avec une
situation économique et sociale très
préoccupante
une situation économique très compliqué
au niger est clairement c'est que quand
vous le sous sol nigérien l'éloignement
qui alimente à quatre parties il
existait dans le contexte français
mais ces différentes ressources sont
tellement sérieusement mal exploité vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'à peine aux
délits geslin s'unissent en d2
l'apparition donc c'est la cour suivant
ça combien le pays fait l'obligé importé
pour mémoire la qualifier de les
généraliser
parce qu'il nya qu intel font partie des
populations
ce qu'il jouait pleinement l'été toutes
ces richesses du sous sol donc un coeur
au-delà de l'aspect démographique dans
le pays fait l'objet la répartition des
p des ressources rêver nos hobbies se
pose avec acuité beaucoup du niger ont
la ferme conviction qui les politiques
qu'ils soient de l'opposition de la
majorité sont en déphasage absolue avec
les attentes légitimes et sénile et en
vis-à-vis de l'offre et la demande du
tcc niger on nous avait dit de l'emploi
beat et toutes ces questions dax hier
les factures de santé de qualité
la facture est négatif de qualité de jeu
pas plus il explique que technicienne de
façon générale elle est un des piliers
par les populations amusé des bolides y
en beaucoup de ressources naturelles au
niger ni l'uranium du phosphate de l'or
du charbon du pétrole de l'étain et
beaucoup beaucoup de pauvreté
comment on explique justement ce
paradoxe qui est trop souvent
malheureusement d'actualité clairement
se parlent plus compétents les conseils
pratiques de benzema
je le paie nièce la mauvaise gouvernance
l'édition de moyens de posséder
l'entretien ont mis en évidence à
combien les slips y sont tellement
galvaudé par une certaine élite
politique en complicité avec des filles
ont différé à charge l'exploitation de
ses différentes ressources naturelles
donc la question de la gouvernance et
elle s'est produit ici
mais dans le même temps il faut que nous
le rappeler pour le second point de
susciter chez c'était d'exploitation
dernièrement au niger
si vous les félins peu le lait ça repart
pour du prince d'andorre oxfam met en
évidence à combien non seulement elle
est différente lit de ses sites naturels
ne sont pas fixés par le niger mais dans
le même temps les mêmes ressources sur
les marchés mondiaux ne sont pas venus
au même prix que si vous prenez des pays
au monde qui exploite également les
mêmes ressources
vous avez un compte que les canadiens il
est comme un scandale les sas que
l'uranium qui ne présente pas moins d'un
tiers de le tester dans le net tout cela
d'un autre comédien cette oligarchie
industriels qui serait une sorte de
mafia la complicité avec une certaine
élite locale institué cette pauvre
d'aussi haut généralisée de l'épitaxie
nigérien est ce que le pourquoi et
nombre important des nigériens en dépit
de l'étendue hostilités à exercer un
contrôle effectif aussi voulu y avait
quand même des médias fait à l'aluminé
cieutat suis désolé vous on est pris par
le temps en tout cas merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur du centre des études
sécuritaires et stratégiques au sahel
merci à vous